be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is pick back
up with some of our previous topics that
have been left hanging over the last few
months and begin by focusing on coming
book concepts and where we've previously
talked about in continuity objects like
the ultimate nullifier in this video I
want to take a step outside of Marvel's
main continuity and talk about the heart
of the universe so the heart of the
universe has an extremely short bit of
history but stands as the most powerful
artifact in the history of Marvel Comics
if we take into account every artifact
from across the landscape appearing for
the first and last time within the story
Marvel the end the story Ezzor was
written by jim Starlin revealed that the
heart of the universe had been created
by the one above all due to the fact
that over the course of the universe's
history heroes had been dying more
frequently than villains meaning that an
imbalance was occurring between the
forces of good and evil to this end the
heart of the universe endowed its
wielder with the power of the one above
all itself and was first encountered by
a race of aliens who look to provide
complete order to the universe by using
the heart to endow one member of the
various races around the universe with
absolute power brainwashing those
individuals to believe in the aliens
absolute construct of law those who were
chosen would enslave their section of
the universe using their abilities and
bring about a rigid stance of law and
order all of which would be controlled
by the aliens themselves as a result and
within the story of Marvel the end a
human name Akhenaten rose to power as a
pharaoh of egypt reigning for around
seventeen years before he vanished and
was pursuing dead however the story
revealed that Akhenaten was selected by
the aliens and endowed with access to
the heart of the universe providing him
with the power to manipulate and control
the very fabric of reality on a
molecular scale using these abilities
Akhenaten appeared before Asgard the sky
fathers and the populace of Earth
stating his intentions to force the
world's population into subservience
while the hero community responded by
coming together in an effort to find the
source of Akhenaten's powers various
villains had looked to usurp Akhenaten
power for themselves to this end dr. Doo
utilizes time platform to travel into
the past and replace Akhenaten when the
aliens came but was thwarted when
Akhenaten used his ability to manipulate
space-time to prevent dooms actions as a
result dr. strange assembled the
original defenders of Silver Surfer the
incredible
namor the sub-mariner who were joined by
Captain Marvel and fan OHS who worked
behind the scenes locating the alien
ship and accessing a source of energy
stumbling upon the heart of the universe
while the rest of the group was
discovered that Oh snuck away and
absorbed the entirety of the heart into
himself
now following this jim Starlin
established that where the Cosmic Cube
allowed its user to create any and
everything and the Infinity Gauntlet
allowed its user to manipulate and
control the facets of the universe the
heart of the universe allowed its
wielder to become one with the universe
itself what this meant was that his
possessor of the heart the power
contained within had become one with
Thanos meaning it couldn't be stripped
away instead the power had to be
willingly given up while the Living
Tribunal appeared before Thanos and
deemed him unworthy of possessing
absolute power because Thanos refused to
give up the hearts power the entirety of
the heroes of the universe were brought
together to engage in a massive battle
however since Thanos had the power of
the one above all Thanos simply destroy
the multiverse in and of itself
eliminating all life within including
the Living Tribunal the cosmic entities
and the universe's heroes leaving
himself as its sole survivor following
this Adam warlock appeared owing to the
fact that he existed outside of space
and time conversing with Thanos directly
Adam warlock revealed that the entire
situation ranging from the creation of
the heart of the universe up to the
current moment had all been engineered
by the one above all who knew that
Thanos would inevitably destroy all
existence thereby correcting the problem
coming to this realization phantoms
recreated the universe but with the
caveat that whenever a hero dies they
will not return and instead will be
replaced by someone new maintaining
balance between good and evil while this
idea was only confined to the universe
at hand the fact remained that with the
recreation of the universe Thanos
destroyed himself ensuring that the
heart of the universe could never be
reformed or recaptured by anyone else
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it and I will catch you all
later peace